andrew garfield appeared on the late
late show with stephen colbert and he
paid a really really touching tribute to
his late mother lynn garfield who died
after a really long battle with
pancreatic cancer it was in 2019. this
is important what he said um it really
is and his new movie tick tick boom
andrew plays the role of uh rent creator
jonathan larson who died of a sudden
illness at 35. uh andrew's older brother
and his dad watched from the audience
and uh he shared how the loss of his mom
impacted his performance and actually
helped him process that grief take a
look
i know that you yourself uh have
suffered great grief
just recently with the loss of your
mother and i'm sorry for your family's
loss thank you and i'm wondering how
doing
this show or any show how art itself
helps you deal with grief yeah um
i love talking about it by the way so if
i cry it's only like
it's only a beautiful thing this is all
the unexpressed love right the grief
that will remain with us
you know
until we pass because we didn't we never
get enough time with each other right
i hope this grief stays with me because
it's all the unexpressed love that i
didn't get to tell her and i told her
every day we all we all told her every
day she was the best of us
and for me i got to sing jonathan
larson's unfinished song
while simultaneously
singing
for my mother
and her unfinished song
and i'm indebted to john and i
and i'm i'm indebted to lin-manuel
miranda
i'm indebted to any everyone who's
brought me to this place so that i can
i can honor
the most beautiful person that i've ever
experienced in my life through my art
and use it as a way to heal use it as a
way to sew up the wounds because that's
what we do right that's what we do
that's what you do every night you sow
up our wounds you sew up our wounds
and and both john and my mother were
artists and they were warriors for art
they knew the power of art and they knew
the power of
leaving the world
in a slightly more beautiful state than
than when they found it so thank you for
letting me talk about her and thank you
for
letting me talk about it with my my two
my two guys up there as well so thank
you steve thank you for sharing